we asked you what is the likelihood that  grease exits the Euro here are some of  the answers the first answer unless  Germany caves the Greek exit is one  hundred percent certain boobster second  answer highly unlikely EU is a political  not an economic Union a mistake markets  tend to repeat payment they will always  figure out a political solution solution  because the politics are more important  than the economics over there well that  dovetails nicely into the third answer 0  Greece is the spoiled kid that when  faced with being cut off gets back and  look what does a ramification quickly  curl if their quote unquote cut off  their cut off well they're cut off you  know they have to live within their  means which is what they do going to do  anyhow whether they stay in a program or  no you're still gonna spay their cell  phone bill well listen I think that's a  lousy metaphor but grief to go on a diet  and they are running a primary surplus  yeah